[Music]
that's Gaga turning the sidewalk into a
cat walk hand-in-hand with boyfriend
Christian Kirino in New York City the 32
year old looked fierce and a leopard
print mini dressed platform boots and a
nearly $5,000 YSL jacket while heading
to a recording studio
the singers been spotted there all week
fueling speculation she's working on a
new album when we'll hear new music
remains a question but in October we'll
see her on the big screen in her first
ever starring role
I don't sing my own songs why I just
don't feel comfortable
Bradlee makes his directorial debut in
the movie about a country music star who
helps an aspiring singer find fame but
the biggest challenge for the 43 year
old was the singing baby it's down
I thought I'd say it was a guy thing
that's okay it's so hard to sing
thankfully he had a six-time Grammy
winner as his leading lady the best part
of it is that we get to have an exchange
with each other because I'm the music
expert and he's the acting expert he
really makes me a better actress Hey
what I just wanna take another look at
you the dual film seems for the movie in
England and around la we spotted them at
the Greek Theatre in May of last year
this is the third remake of the 1937
film the most recent was in 1976 and
starred Barbra Streisand and Kris
Kristofferson and won an Oscar Netflix
just released that version with new
scenes in anticipation of Bradley and
Gaga's upcoming remake which took 42
days to shoot and after nearly three
years in development even celebrities
are eagerly awaiting the premiere I'll
be there opening night front row right
popcorn ready I can't wait to see it
congratulations I think it's a great
film for her I know she'll do a great
job
[Music]
I am NOT gonna light it I didn't think I
would be this excited to see this film
looks good everybody a star is born in
theatres October 5th
[Music]